monsieur le premier ministre le chef de
l'état vous a choisi pour diriger le
gouvernement de la france
il a même eu la délicatesse de choisir
aussi vos principaux collaborateurs
mais n'oubliez jamais que désormais vous
êtes le premier ministre de la france
et n'oubliez pas non plus que dans la
république il n'y a qu'un seul souverain
c'est le peuple français c'est lui et
lui seul que vous devez servir dans le
cadre de nos institutions républicaines
dit caméral vous l'avez site et nous
avons été touchés je voudrais simplement
redire ce que disait le plus célèbre
sans doute des sénateurs victor hugo
après bien sûr le président larcher la
france dirigée par une assemblée unique
ce serait la mère gouverné par l'ouragan
ce sont nos institutions et si vous êtes
attaché à votre prime gaulliste vous
vous en souviendrez votre tâche est
lourde à l'image de la lourde épreuve
qui accablent depuis plusieurs mois de
notre pays elle exige de vous le
meilleur et elle exige aussi de nous de
la hauteur j'entends depuis que vous
êtes nommé de nombreux commentaires qui
cherchent à déterminer quel premier
ministre
vous serez mais l'important n'est pas là
peu importe le premier ministre que vous
serez ce qui importe c'est ce que vous
ferez peu importe votre accent chantant
agréable à écouter je dois le dire
simplement cet accent est aussi la
preuve vocale de ce que disait impôts
est le reflet du sol sur les âmes
mais ce qui compte au bout du compte ce
sera la partition de vos décisions des
actes que vous poserez des actes que
vous poserez dans une dans des
circonstances tellement difficile pour
la france avec des crises plusieurs
crises en boîte et comme des poupées
russes les unes dans les autres crises
sanitaires crise économique et sociale
et pas la moindre
et je terminerai sur celle ci la crise
civique la crise sanitaire
il vous faudra énormément d'énergie plus
d'énergie que jusqu'ici
vos prédécesseurs n'ont déployé pour
éviter une résurgence j'en prends à
témoin deux exemples et masques
il a fallu cinq mois nous le réclamions
ici à plusieurs reprises cinq mois pour
rendre obligatoire et ça n'est pas
encore fait les masques dans les
endroits publics clos pareil pour le
dépistage entendu présent république
dire mais on a les capacités mais on n'a
pas la demande
non c'est pas qu'on a pas la demande on
n'a pas la stratégie monsieur le premier
ministre pour tester on nous avait
promis 700 mille tests on en fait deux
fois moins
il faut pas attendre la plupart des cas
sont asymptomatiques
il faut tester pourquoi avoir interdit
d'ailleurs les entreprises volontaires
les salariés volontaires
des dépistages systématiques il faut
donc beaucoup plus d'énergie pour régler
évidemment cette crise sanitaire pour
éviter la résurgence
et puis il ya la crise économique et
sociale
la france est à la croisée des chemins
et nous avons un choix terrible entre le
relèvement
il est possible ou entre
l'engourdissement c'est à dire le
décrochage le déclin les décisions vous
serez amené à prendre dans les
prochaines semaines les prochains mois
détermineront l'avenir de la france pas
seulement pour ce quinquennat mais sans
doute pour 10 ou 15 ans qui viennent et
partout c'est une course contre la
montre les nations du monde les nations
européennes ont commencé cette course à
la reprise économique
nous ne sommes pas bien placé vous
l'avez dit vous-même -11% c'est sans
doute un des plus mauvais résultats dans
le monde développé en matière de
violence de la récession
il faudra agir agir vite sur deux
urgences simultanément l'urgence sociale
avec le chômage le chômage sans doute
des salariés il faut a toujours préféré
financer des dépenses active
d'investissement en compétences former
plutôt que licencier puis à les jeunes
ne vous enfermez pas dans les recettes
du passé
vous ne bâtir et pas l'avenir avec des
vieilles solutions les contrats aidés
préféré pour ces jeunes qui sont souvent
sans qualification qui ont connu un
échec scolaire
et ferrer des contrats d'apprentissage
d'une nouvelle façon nous avons les
propositions monsieur le premier
ministre à vous faire et si vous le
voulez bien nous les ferons bien sûr
l'urgence sociale d'abord l'urgence
économique
ensuite la clé du relèvement c'est la
croissance c'est la croissance mes chers
collègues qui paiera nous dette c'est la
croissance qui protégera les français du
déclassement de l'appauvrissement aussi
bien collectif qu'individuel
mais pour aller chercher le potentiel de
croissance il faut agir agir puissamment
sur deux secteurs de secteurs de
facteurs sur lesquels la france est
faible trop faible l'offre de travail
bien sûr les compétences augmenter les
compétences de ceux qui en france
travaillent mais aussi travailler
davantage
je ne connais pas dans nos expériences
individuelles dans les expériences
historiques collective de grande épreuve
surmontée dans la facilité oui il faudra
du courage
oui il faut dire la vérité aux français
et tourner le dos à tous les mensonges
qu'on leur a fait depuis des années
évidemment pour ce qui concerne cette
croissance potentielle il y à l'offre de
travail mais ici il y à la compétitivité
qui est en berne comme l'expriment
depuis tant d'années le déficit du
commerce extérieur et pour cela il
faudra baisser les impôts mais c'est les
impôts de production a commencé vous
devriez le faire maintenant dans le plfr
3 la c3s dès maintenant baisser les
charges au delà de 1,6 smic
parce que si vous ne le faites pas vous
désavantagés l'industrie et vous voulez
pourtant rien du trias lisez la france
vous devez faire annuler le forfait
social
pas seulement sur les tpe et les pme
mais aussi les deux pays
si vous voulez vraiment relancer
puissamment la participation si vous
vous dites gaulliste social annulé le
forfait social
faites le maintenant n'attendez pas la
rentrée n'attendez pas demain sans
compétitivité il n'y aura pas de
souveraineté économique sans
relocalisation sans compétitivité il n'y
aura pas deux
ré industrialisation et donc de mobilité
sociale parce que de tous les pays
d'europe comme vous le savez c'est la
france qui s'est le plus tertiarisée
nous avons remplacé des salaires de 48
50 mille euros par des salaires plus
modestes dans le tertiaire
donc il faut déployer les voiles avec ce
glaive le glaive la compétitivité de la
productivité mais aussi un bouclier le
bouclier européen
c'est l'allemagne qui depuis quelques
jours mes chers collègues cher jean
bizet préside l'union européenne
c'est avec l'allemagne que les liens se
sont un peu rôtissent et il faut les
renforcer
exiger ce bouclier européen exiger un
changement de logiciel pour la
concurrence acceptera ton demain face
aux chinois et à la planète d'avoir des
champions européens pour ça il faut
changer le logiciel de la concurrence
exige et défendez la pac
défendez une politique agricole commune
bien sûr mais défendent et aussi une
autre conception du libre échange et
nous attendons madame la ministre vous
qui êtes chargé l'écologie nous
attendons avec impatience au sénat qu'on
transmette au sénat à notre assemblée
pour qu'elle puisse enfin voter le ceta
pour que nous puissions voté contre
mercer collègues parce que le ceta n'est
pas bon ni pour l'agriculture ni non
plus pour la planète et nous le ferons
nous ferons ce que nous disons et nous
le voterons nous voterons contre bien
sûr le ceta et puis enfin exigé comme je
n'ai entendu d'hervé marseille à
quelques instants une frontière wiertz
c'est à dire une frontière carbone ce
sera bon là encore pour le climat et ça
sera encore meilleure du reste pour les
emplois il faudra beaucoup de courage
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
de la sincérité et je pense que vous
avez du courage je n'en doute pas même
il faudra beaucoup de courage il faudra
tourner le dos aux idées toutes faites
un jour discutant avec un journaliste un
auteur que j'aime beaucoup hannah arendt
avait dealé crise ne devienne
catastrophique que lorsqu'on y répond
avec des façons tout fait
c'est à dire par des préjugés et oui il
faudra que vous tourniez aussi le dos à
tous ces préjugés à toutes les vieilles
recettes
oui il vous faut déboulonner les statues
pas les statuts qui nous surplombe la
statue de saint louis
lassitude porte à liszt et la statue de
colbert que malicieusement le président
du sénat a mis juste dans son alignement
et dans le vôtre les statuts quand je
parle mes chers collègues ce sont les
statuts virtuel ses idoles ses mensonges
la première c'est l'argent facile argent
magique qui peut croire qu'ils peuvent
croire
qui peut croire que demain
jamais nos créanciers n'exigeront le
remboursement de leurs créances qui peut
le croire
qui peut croire que demain les nations
en europe qui compteront auront été les
nations qu'ils en ont dépensé sans
compter
qui peut le penser avec certitude et
puis il ya d'autres 7,6 virtuelle celle
qui consiste par exemple à faire de la
dépense publique
le seul critère la mesure la seule
mesure de l'efficacité de l'état de
l'efficacité des services publics
c'est ce que vous faites malheureusement
actuellement avec le grenelle de la
santé bien sûr il fallait revaloriser
les carrières les salaires des
personnels présents mais revalorisé
faire un chèque de 8 milliards sans ne
rien dire de la tarification du
financement d'hôpital de sa gouvernance
mais aussi de son organisation ses
sisyphe
c'est le tonneau des danaïdes monsieur
le premier ministre donc il faut
réformer
bien sûr et il faut dire la vérité et
non seulement avoir le courage de le
dire mais surtout le courage de faire
puisque vous disiez il ya quelques temps
vous étiez plutôt un taiseux et un
faisons bien sûr et puis je terminerais
parce qu'elle est fondamentale et
qu'elle commande sans doute peut-être
tout le reste par la crise syrie ma
certitude est que en réalité pour
relever pour redresser l'économie d'un
pays
les ressorts du développement économique
sans doute matériel mais ils sont avant
tout immatériel ils sont avant tout un
matériel parce que et vous l'avez moins
prononcé dans ce discours qui hier
hier vous avez dû prononcer une
quinzaine de fois je crois le mot
confiance et bien la confiance est
immatériel
c'est un climat c'est une atmosphère
c'est une relation entre les uns et les
autres les citoyens mais sans confiance
il ne peut pas y avoir de croissance et
nous sommes le peuple de tous les
peuples européens voiliers qui avons le
moins confiance dans l'avenir qui sommes
les plus sceptiques vis-à-vis de nos
dirigeants
très franchement je vous bien nous
mettre dans le même paquet je pense que
les français nous mettent dans le même
paquet monsieur le premier ministre je
ne distingue pas nous nous distinguons
pas par rapport au gouvernement
mais ce que je vous dis c'est que les
français ont sans doute quelques raisons
d'être aussi sceptique d'être aussi
défiant parce que tous les piliers de
nos institutions
les uns après les autres ont été
ébranlés ébranlé défier la république
défier à dijon quand les règlement de
différends entre les bandes se règle non
pas au commissariat ou à la préfecture
mais dans une mosquée défier la
république quand les enclaves
communautarise séparatistes se
multiplient partout en france
et quand dans ces enclaves on n'échappe
à la règle commune
c'est la république bien sûr qui est
défiée défier fragiliser la démocratie
quand on a tous constaté le taux de
participation l'abstention dramatique
aux élections locales
fragilisé la démocratie quand vous
légitimez le tirage au sort la
démocratie du hasard la démocratie de la
courte paille mes collègues
et oui la justification de la
décentralisation c'est d'abord d'essayer
de recoudre le fil de la confiance dans
la proximité et avec la loi note et
d'autres textes nous avions construit au
contraire la société de la défiance
c'est à dire la société de l'éloignement
vous devrez construire la société du
rapprochement la société de la proximité
la proximité c'est l'efficacité
nous l'avons montré en pleine crise eu
copie c'est en même temps la proximité
le lien social
le lieu c'est le lien hommes de
territoire que vous êtes et en même
temps la proximité c'est l'espace de
confiance c'était un espace qu'il faut
reconstruire mais ne fait pas la
différenciation avant de faire de la
décentralisation poser d'abord un cadre
général
et ensuite vous différencier mais fait
pâle inverse vous mettrez la charrue
avant les boeufs je veux vous le dire au
nom de mango aujourd'hui solennellement
la démocratie et enfin l'état nation lui
aussi fragilisé l'état nation qui est
notre façon d'être au monde
cette figure historique collective
française qui est terriblement ébranlé
état nation l'état l'état
bureaucratiques qui s'est formidablement
dilate et à mesure que l'état régalien
s'est rétracté pas un mot du président
de la république mes chers collègues le
14 juillet sur le meurtre d'une jeune
gendarme pas un mot non plus sur le
lynchage à bayonne d'un chauffeur de bus
est bien à aiguillon ou à bayonne
c'est la loi de la violence ordinaire
qui a prévalu la france est désormais de
tous les pays d'europe
celui qui affiche le taux d'homicides
proportionnellement à son nombre
d'habitants le plus élevé alors
franchement construire et voulait prison
est ce que le numerus clausus carcéral
tiendra lieu encore de politique pénale
ce sont des questions concrètes
auxquelles vous devrez répondre parce
que l'état a été fragilisée et la nation
la nation française déchiré son tissu
déchirée pas un communautariste par un
séparatisme parent sécessionnisme qui
n'ont trouvé en face d'eux pour
l'instant qu'une pensée molle que des
actes faible que ferez vous reprendrez
vous et proposition du sénat en matière
d'interdiction par exemple des signes
ostentatoires lors des sorties scolaires
il y aura des actes concrets à poser là
aussi des décisions urgentes courageuse
apprendre la nation fragilisé quand
certains veulent l'avoir désigné comme
coupable
éternellement coupables coupables de
culpabilité comme disait un personnage
dans un film de bergman
les fraises sauvages mais si pour être
aimable la france voit d'abord se
reconnaître coupable comment nous
français si nous avions seulement de
notre histoire une vision
lacrymal et pénitentielle comment
pouvons-nous nous projeter dans l'avenir
pour surmonter l'épreuve
comment est-ce qu'on peut si on dit que
la france est un contre-modèle vouloir
que les jeunes générations qui sont sur
la voie de la sécession
puis s'agréger le destin collectif je
vous le demande comment vous devrez
porter fièrement les couleurs de la
nation française
nos valeurs aussi alors pour terminer
monsieur le premier ministre je serais
bref pour dire que la conviction qui
nous habite et qui m'habite c'est que
vous ne pourrez pas répondre à la
dépression économique et sociale sans
répondre à la dépression cilic
c'est à dire à la défiance la défiance
et les filles de l'impuissance
cette impuissance plus aucun artifice de
communication désormais arrive ne
parvient à la masquer la politique crève
elle crève de cette obsession de crever
l'écran
depuis le début du quinquennat sans
doute aussi avant évidemment beaucoup de
français ont été perdus et ils sont
perdus ceux qui veulent retrouver dans
la politique ce n'est pas un nouveau
chemin ce n'est même pas un nouveau
monde
ceux qui veulent retrouver c'est la
france la france avec son audace la
france avec sa fierté
la france avec sa destinée un peuple
libre unie face à l'épreuve unis dans un
idéal français qui est l'est d'el al qui
nous rassemble quelles que soient nos
appartenances partisanes ou géographique
c'est cet idéal français il doit
dessiner notre chemin il doit dessiner
la seule perspective si vous l'emprunt
très nous serons à vos côtés si vous en
détourner nous combattrons votre
politique
vive la république et vive la france
[Musique]